you did something I've always wanted to
do I've never been to Russia and I've
always wanted to go to Russia it's one
of my dreams to go to Russia and check
it out because it just seems like such a
fascinating place and I've read about a
lot it and then I find out that you
spent a semester in Russia yeah it was
where I did my abroad study there yeah I
all I wanted to do is go to Russia
because of being like a theater geek and
loving Chekhov
sure yeah yeah yeah they think you're
talking with the guy from Star Trek yeah
no but I'm serious well I mean first of
all what's it like what did you know the
place when I went it was 2009 so there
was like pre invading Ukraine pre Sochi
Olympics and anti homophobic laws so
it's like a much more likeable country
right it was the free and easygoing
Russian yeah where all of the crap net
was more hidden the free it easily
Russia which never existed yeah so when
I was there but I was a student so I got
to be I got to be like with all the
people and that's the greatest thing
about Russians is that Russian people
are remarkable they're incredible and
they've survived such crazy things yes
and it was also it was fun I was 19 and
I've you know drinking ages 18 and they
truly believe this vodka is like the
end-all be-all and Carroll they yeah
apparently they think I've heard that
they I mean we all know they they drink
vodka they like vodka that's their drink
but that they they think it actually
cures all ailments right medicinal it's
medicinal
my father would be proud that he also
believes it's literally in that country
if someone's like got a gunshot wound in
the throat they're like have vodka you
need to have it and they'll pour I mean
it's very useful but um yeah I had a
stomach issue and and the woman who is
like this older woman who took care of
us as our home mom person she made me
take a shot of vodka I felt so sick and
that was about the last thing I wanted
in my body and she made me take a shot
of vodka to cure my stomach problem and
did it work I don't have a memory of if
it worked
that's the key to the vodka fear is you
you wake up four days later and you
don't know what happened but people
would would take shots of it and then go
running if they felt sick so they could
sweat it I sweat it out ya see a lot of
drunken running people yeah yeah do you
speak any Russian choo choo is what you
say a little bad shoot nobody here
speaks Russian obviously it's weird
because usually we get an all Russian
crowd Burbank has just a thriving oh
yeah I Bank
yeah lots of rock yeah so so shoot shoot
means a little it means a little what
are the words that you would eat that
you learned that are cool I mean I would
repeat that
well I the ones that really stuck behind
I think anytime you learn a language is
like the curse words right but I don't
know the ones I would want to know the
dirty words oh god I feel weird being on
television saying like another country's
dirty words but like I said this isn't
what you remember any words you conceit
yes yes there's there's a big piece
debts yes yes yes that's a bad one is it
PZ it's I he's debts you can't tell me I
mean I don't think I can say it in
English either really like you can't say
it or it's a bad word that you can't say
on TV no it's it's like the female
region oh I think yeah it's the female
region it that's no fun yeah and then
quote-unquote it's the I like to make it
clear I think the female region is fine
there's there's but I yet which is a
really fun one dissenter yet yet yet yet
i paid yet yeah like [ __ ] well that's
yeah that's when people would use all
the time yeah Britt yes and they all and
they combine them all together like
Tourette's ago these it's not wholly B
it's and they're just like screaming
they're yelling female region yeah and
then not boy what it's not hi know who I
mean believe it means on the penis like
the direct translation I think on the
beat wow that's a fun string of words
you just say wait why would there be a
word for on the penis I don't know okay
that's just well there's a lot to
process here where did I put that TV
remote it's on the penis
[Laughter]
you